scott this is great uh before the show
started you've been working with sal
you've worked with sal many times
my [ __ ] is gone my [ __ ] is gone
and you uh were able over zoom to put
him in a hypnotic state we wanted you
to hypnotize sound to thinking that he's
a medium and that
he uh has the ability to contact the
dead i told him he had the power
in the ability to connect with anything
that's living or has passed on to
another realm
sal is in the green room saying to gary
that the legendary leslie west great
guitar player
who just recently passed leslie west
wants to talk to sal
first cell looked like he was stoned
right and i go what's going on and he
goes
my heart's beating really hard he goes
you know how did leslie die heart attack
and i said yeah i think so and he goes
i'm not trying to do this but leslie is
he's talking to me
i'm getting leslie west right now i'm
not kidding you big time at my heart
he's just here with me i don't know why
i didn't ask for leslie west i'm just
telling you like leslie is here
big time without further ado let's bring
in
psychic sal all right sale why don't you
get comfortable
close your eyes and take a slow deep
breath in
let it out and relax and go into that
very
deep deep hypnotic state you were in
before
sal are you speaking with the great
guitar player leslie west
yes i am what is leslie telling you
this guy is like the greatest guy ever
his his energy is amazing
he's so loving so caring this guy
does not judge anyone he's saying to me
sal i got your back
um he's not as heavy as he was back in
the
early days of mountain but he has a
little bit of a belly just to show you
that
that was his favorite time is it
possible that
leslie could bring other dead people to
us like i'm fascinated to ask nicole
brown simpson who killed her
uh once and for all here just tell why
don't you do this why don't you look at
your doorway
i don't need your help scott i have this
got it yeah i'm there you're there
good wow that was like bigger than the
long island media
nicole has one concern and it's her
children that's it that's all she cares
about she doesn't care about
the media she doesn't care about
who was caught she's saying to me
uh-huh she and she says we know who did
it
um she says that all the focus is on the
circus
and not her kids and her kids are
suffering the most
from all of this nobody talks about the
kids she feels the children's pain
every day and she said it's overwhelming
and she wishes she could reach out to
her kids
everything else does not matter not one
bit nothing
well that is unbelievable sal i mean i
see you're in tears
is this a tremendous pain pal
it's ridiculous it's beyond tremendous
what about eric the actor who was such a
big success on this show is he
are you able to open the portal sal and
talk to eric i mean there's so many
people i'd love to communicate with i
don't want to over
tax you how are you doing how is eric
yes
any any side of him yes oh
good he's glowing tell him
he's probably flying with balloons he
laughed and set it back
and he said it clearly his voice is not
like that anymore
he looks like he's six foot tall
um great hair he's got great looks his
face is still the same
but it's more handsome much
much more handsome well then who wants
to talk to him that isn't that funny
if life is good who cares he's saying
you made him happy he's glowing
happy are you sure it's eric you eric
the actor
yes what's one last thing we can do with
sal let's uh
you know what about his conversation
with a squirrel
i would love to hear about that all
right take a deep breath and just clear
everything
and what i want you to do is i want you
to think about that
conversation you had that connection you
had with that squirrel
you talked about on the show a few weeks
ago i locked eyes
and communicated with a squirrel
squirrel what were you trying to tell
sal
i was trying to tell sal that we
are all connected there's synchronicity
throughout the world
even the sea is alive
water is alive do you love being a
squirrel
is it like really awesome i love being a
squirrel
are you a male squirrel or a female
squirrel i am a male squirrel
and how many squirrel women have you
impregnated how many children do you
have
uh you like that
that sounds to me like a lot the big
numbers oh the squirrel's
like a real player yeah i do
as a squirrel i do enjoy
having as much sex as possible but you
have a little squirrel [ __ ] right i mean
that's how it works just like with
people i have
the genitalia that
is uh fitting to me to my body
it's in proportion to me and do you have
a particular type of squirrel you like
like a big
bushy tail or a big ass is there some
physical part of a squirrel that you're
really into you know you'd like it all
any squirrel anymore any squirrel will
do do you ever have sex with male
squirrels like is there
homosexuality in the squirrel community
i don't have sex with male squirrels but
there have been male squirrels who have
pressed up against me and and have who
have ejaculated on me
and i don't care another male
uh no on my side on the side of my hip
when was the last team i heard sale
describe sexual activity in such
clinical terms
i know i mean as a squirrel he has a lot
more class
like a professor and well well scott
this has been amazing
you know what if you want to try one
more thing why don't we see if there's
somebody who's looking to come through
instead of asking for
a specific person maybe there's somebody
that has a specific message that wants
to
go and talk i would love that sale i
want you to
take a deep breath in goodbye squirrel
exhale out just clear your mind
just turn up the power on your radio
transmitter and receiver to the
connection of the universe
okay okay i have somebody she's been
standing here
for a while i don't all right
i i don't know who this is for i feel
it's definitely i feel strongly for
howard
but this is an older woman i think she's
i was gonna say mother but i think she's
on your father's side
thank you the name is with an m it's
mary
there's a mary in your life sal came up
with mary
there's a marriage it's my life not
yours it's not mary's in the stern line
i know i know but she okay so mary how
does that mean
for you when scott told you to clear
your mind i guess that you you took it
too literally
she doesn't find that i had enough of
this listen sal
uh she does not find that funny she has
one message for you cut it out
and all right i hate to break it to you
the afterlife exists
look who he found in the world of the
afterlife we say come up with somebody
came up with mary
right cut it out her message was cut it
[Music]
out